interesting very interesting approach
who threw the chicken nugget yup Harry
Styles pauses his concert after a fan
throws chicken nuggets at him
you want it back why
because
all right here we go nothing really goes
to plan you can say that again seems
like things didn't go as planned for
these fans either
a Downy chicken
sorry
I'll donate me yeah Harry turns down his
Madison Square Garden audience's request
for him to have a mid-show snack but he
has some fun while declining the offer
all right here we go
donate it it's out now it's on the floor
don't go looking for it we'll get you
another nugget okay I was definitely an
orb not eating meat is reason enough not
to indulge in the chicken surprise and
so is this first of all
this is cold
foreign
and I'm assuming very old
next time might we suggest watermelon
watermelon sugar
[Music]
that chicken moment played out at
Harry's latest love on tour concert stop
[Music]
s
across the river at Madison Square
Garden he's about to go on stage
congratulations Howard these NYC
performance conflicted with Sunday's
Video Music Awards where Harry won album
of the year I'm sorry I can't be there
with you tonight I'm about to go on
stage uh just down the road but the
musician didn't make time to pre-record
his acceptance speech celebrating his
latest album Harry's house
I hope you're having a nice time I'm
Harry thank you so so much for this
award for album of the year
um I know this is a fan voted award I
would like to say thank you to all of my
friends who voted thank you so so much
I obviously wouldn't be holding this if
it wasn't for you and while we would
have loved to have seen Harry rock out
at the VMAs where you wouldn't have this
moment if he'd been there interesting
very interesting approach
who threw the chicken nuggets
[Music]